i think nfts are going to be
a framework that we trade in collecting
utility
in access in for the rest of our
collective lives
you've got your perspective
i just want to be happy don't you want
to be happy
[Music]
our first guest is a media maestro
serial entrepreneur and prominent
internet personality he co-founded
restaurant reservation app resi which i
use from time to time
and was an early angel investor tech
firms like facebook twitter
and venmo joining us now is gary
vaynerchuk
chair of vaynerx and the ceo of vader
media welcome gary
welcome to the show thanks for having me
how are you guys
all right great all right great to have
you great
all right so you know we just had people
on
last week we have midikovan the buyer of
his 70 million dollar
nft later on the show are we in an
nft bubble what do you what are your
thoughts on that people said
we he thought he we were do you agree
i do i think that we are in a very
similar place to where we were
in internet stocks in 2000 i think
when you have these massive
transformation technology
shifts there's a moment where everybody
gets excited
about it and you know for me the
internet
was happening in 95 6 7
but you started to really see the stock
market embrace with those ipos in 98.99
and then obviously in april uh
march april 2000 you had the the
collapsing of it
at the time of the stocks at the time a
lot of people talked about the internet
being a fad
and that never being meaningful for
businesses blah blah blah
what what happened in reality was the
internet was this game-changing
revolution of technology
but a lot of the early projects were
just overpriced on the excitement
i think we're absolutely in the
replication of this
i think nfts are going to be a framework
that we trade in collecting
utility in access in
for the rest of our collective lives but
i think some of the projects that you're
seeing right now
on the individual pieces um
are going to burst
so you have a long experience in in in
marketing and are obviously quite
skilled at that
until recently bitcoin was widely
considered to have a marketing problem
like people just didn't get it like
people the the mainstream just didn't
get it now that's changed a little bit
just because of the price
but if you were if you had to give kind
of like the elevator pitch for bitcoin
like the quick
marketing sound bite what would you say
like how would you how would you sell
bitcoin to the masses
um you know to me you know if i was
selling bitcoin i would
i would speak about history you know why
did gold
do xyz why did fiat happen like what is
what is the human psychology to
acceptance
i would speak about things that could
happen
like what if amazon accepts it
what if xyz country invests
aggressively at it so i think there's a
lot of logical steps to continue
the uh affirmation and confirmation of
the currency and i think history
has proven that and and i would use
history
and examples of one domino effect
that could change the outcome for the
people that are cynical about it
so just to follow up on that how would
you how would you market nfts you know
if at nfts like right now there's all
these people being like why is someone
spending 70 million
on a jpeg like if you just had to
quickly explain to somebody what the
value is of an nft what would you say
i usually go down the route of do you
know somebody who's bought a fortnight
skin for a hundred bucks
comma do you think a blue check on
instagram
is worth something comma i educate them
for a minute on the metadata on the nfts
and speak about
access membership clubs vip treatments
one-on-one dinners and talk about all
the charity events and
things that are sold when people get
access to things that they can't get
access to
so getting back to the topic you know
keeping on this whole idea of the nft
bubble etc
um nonetheless uh nfts
how would you translate that into the
into the real world how would you
translate
you know you've been in the business of
selling physical goods
so how would you translate the nft from
intellectual property
into the physical world how will how
will that come about
i think people really under
underestimating and undereducated on the
smart contracts
and the reality is you could sell the
digital asset then deliver the
individual
the physical good but then in the smart
contract let me give an example
if i decide i have a book coming out in
november but then i'm a free agent and i
was going to sign another book deal now
i'm debating
should i just nft my book after that
print 200 000 copies
make an nft replication of the cover
make 190
000 uh that look exactly like the cover
and if you buy
it for 20 bucks the nft i send you the
book it's literally and you have now
this little digital asset
that you might be able to trade on to
make some of your dollars back or what
have you but then there's ten thousand
covers left
nine thousand of those can be silver
covers and they may be a hundred dollars
but what that does in the smart contract
is it allows you to be part of my book
club and once a month
once a week whenever i decide in the
smart contract i will go with that small
group and do q a and learnings that
leaves a hundred gold books
that might be things like one-on-one
dinners or a live conference
and maybe one platinum book that is
somebody that gets to spend a month with
me
the access underneath the smart contract
i think is going to end up being
the aha for a lot of people as they
become more educated that it's not just
a jpeg
not to mention people care about the
ownership of provenance
and as that becomes social currency and
the way we live it's no different than
in 1999 when i told my friends that
everybody would online date
and they lasted me out of the room they
were unable to see the chess moves to
how
society would evolve i believe in 15
years people are going to look at
people's public wallets
to see what they have bought to become a
conversation
piece or a social currency layer
the way that logos are the way that
followers on social media are
the way that your wikipedia or google
search results are
that's funny you say that because i'm
about to do that right now with you
gary you tweeted in 2013 that you just
bought
using bitcoin google smart pants and had
it
delivered by a drone in 21 minutes first
of all
must be a very expensive pair of pants
in today's dollar terms and seconds
you know you know what was your
experience with paying
something with bitcoin should it be used
as a currency what
what are your thoughts on that
should be i apologize my experience was
in 2013 good
yeah should be should bitcoin be used as
a currency
it is it's not even a should this is not
about predictions people accept bitcoin
all the time it's it's already happened
the question becomes
what happens next i i think this you
know bitcoin is so much further along
than the majority of things that have
come before it
as an accepted currency to me
i don't get to say nor do most humans
get to say what should or shouldn't be
accepted
if enough people believe in it then it
becomes
you know i always remind people somebody
used to live in the world before gold
meant
anything you know we we didn't have
great documentation
but gold was a created ecosystem
should gold be expected what should be
the currency of the world
is my question to you whatever
enough of the people in the world accept
right humans create their ecosystems
i don't think i don't think this is a
game of should this is a game of how has
it always happened
people used to trade berries for sheeps
people used to trade
furs for for people uh people used to
trade
high-end wine for workers to build
things i mean
i i laugh at people's naivete to think
what is going on today
or what we grew up with is the end-all
be-all
uh that that's just laughable the human
race will continue to evolve
and if anything i think it makes more
sense
that things that are digital become the
currency
as we go that route as a race do you see
bitcoin becoming the currency of the
world that everyone
will start using and
you know i like to answer things that i
understand and you can see the
conviction i come in on the other
questions
i really don't know you know for me the
reason i've gone harder into nft
than let's say currencies is because i
just enjoy it more
you know i i wasn't the kind of person
that really traded
equities my whole life i haven't spent
the meaningful hours that i think other
people have around
really being able to answer that
question what i can tell you is
people are naive and if they don't
understand
that a shocking number of people have
accepted this
i think there's a lot of conversation of
what happens to
the dollar when it goes off of the gold
standards in the 70s
i think there's a lot going on with our
society
and our relationships with governments
and i think
the ingredients are in place for
bitcoin and you know you've got to
understand if bitcoin hits
and becomes a currency of society
well that leads to a lot of other
currencies and a lot of other variables
like nfts to also follow suit
and it creates a real digital finance
economy
so for a long time people have been
getting really frustrated with our
current social media platforms in
particular
facebook right in terms of you know
keeping our data selling our data you
know
individuals having limited control um
over these sort of centralized platforms
and but we still haven't really seen
anything truly disrupt the current model
the sort of facebook twitter model
um i guess my question is how do you see
the future of social media and do you
think blockchain technology will play a
part of it do you see a
decentralized social media uh coming in
the future
i do see a decentralized social media i
do think on the flip side
that our great disgust with facebook inc
is more of a mainstream media headline
than reality i haven't seen this grand
exodus from instagram
because they sell our data you know i
when you talk to normal people it's like
talking about
defy or bitcoin or nfts most people
speak about it from a headline
standpoint but can't actually articulate
what they're so upset about
when they quote unquote sell our data
it's not like people are surveillancing
our life
they're creating a scenario where we are
getting more relevant advertising
in our feeds based on our clicks and our
actions
this great propaganda that these
machines are manipulating us
is laughable you can absolutely delete
the app
so you know there are two separate
things i think the reason you haven't
seen
anything too crazy is real life humans
are not so up in arms
for seeing root beer ads in their feed
because they like root beer
comma i do think a decentralized central
network
is inevitable because decentralization
is here
right like the technology is here and
every aspect
of our society will play on top of it
so uh along those lines do you have an
expectation for instance
for where the price of bitcoin will be
in
a couple of years from now uh based on
just the
overall change in the economy and and
how people view
uh networks and how they they trade
currency etc
i you know you know what's funny my
friend i don't tend to predict i'm very
good at
seeing something and then tasting it
using it
and having observations here's what i
will say
i will say that there i don't believe
there's a really
i i don't believe there's a middle
ground for bitcoin
i think it's so far advanced that
unless you have government involvement i
think it will continue to go up
and then if you do have massive
government regulations if
if russia america europe decides to say
you are
if you are a citizen of our our state
our sovereign nation you are not allowed
to hold this i think you've got a whole
nother bag of issues
and a whole who knows what comes out of
that but i don't think there's this
middle ground for a very long time i
think you got another decade max
of potential middle ground and then it's
going to
space or you're going to have real
interesting
unrest between citizens and sovereign
nations
thanks
all right thank you so much gary for
joining us this morning and sharing your
thoughts always a pleasure
thanks for having me team bye-bye
youtube watcher what's up it's garyvee
first of all thank you so much i hope
you're doing super well during these
times i also want to ask you please
subscribe because my
commitment and exploration of youtube is
about to explode stories polls
more content more engagement more
surprise and delight
this is the time to subscribe i hope you
consider it and i hope i see you soon